If you've been using the simulator
keyboard to test out your version
of me me,
you may have noticed a little problem.
Especially when editing
this bottom text field.
[NOISE] The keyboard covers up the text
field, and leaves the user stuck.
One can avoid this by shifting
the entire view up, like so.
To isolate the keyboard issue,
let's build a simple app.
Here I've got an app with
a text field in an image.
The text field's at the bottom and
it gets covered up if we
don't shift the view.
Shifting the view a simple.
Remember way back when we built
click counter from scratch in code?
To place our views we
use the frame property.
That's the property we'll use
to shift the main view up.
More specifically, frame.origin.why.
The point where y = 0 is
at the top of the screen.
To move the view up above the keyboard,
we subtract the height
of the keyboard like so.
But how will we know when
the keyboard is about to slide up?
This is where NSNotifications come in.
In short, NSNotifications provide a way
to announce information throughout
a program across classes.
To announce information, like
the keyboard appearing or disappearing.
For more details, see the upcoming text
note on the NSnotification center.
Kind of like we subscribe to mailing
lists, objects have to subscribe to, or
observe, notifications.
In this block of code,
the view controller is signing up to
be notified when an event is coming up.
The event, UIKeyboard will show.
We'll call the
subscribeToKeyboardNotifications method
up here, and view will appear.
When the event UIKeyboardWillShow occurs
The method Keyboard Will Show is called
and that method shifts the frame.
But right now the compiler is
complaining because we haven't
implemented this get
Keyboard Height method.
Notifications carry information
in the user info dictionary.
The UI keyboard Will Show notification
carries the keyboard frame in
its user info dictionary.
So that's how we get
the keyboard height.
So now let's see this
keyboard shift in action.
But let's not forget,
just like with mailing lists
eventually we need to unsubscribe.
So here's the method to unsubscribe
from keyboard notifications.
And we'll call this unsubscribe method
up here in view will disappear.